what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I held on as long as I could but
reading the new Green Lanterns story
basically training day is what it is
late the whole training story with Simon
Baz and Jessica Cruz we have to start
going over Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's now we already did sinestro's
law which is the opening story for Hal
Jordan in the Green Lantern's rubberband
giddy you are an amazing guy okay so I
guess now guys you're never gonna
believe this sort so so we're in Chicago
for CTV to myself and Benny our comics
we're hanging out with Robert Van Betty
we were talking about something I said
what it was no I was trying to convince
him to tell me something that happens in
house one in the Green Lanterns an event
it seems like it's being in Watchmen and
he wouldn't tell me what it was and so
he was like aren't you the guy that got
on Twitter and was like hey everybody
like what's your favorite story from DC
rebirth and why is it Superman and I was
like no man I was just messing around it
was pretty fun he's a really really cool
guy he's really fun to hang out with but
anyways so with regards to how Jordan
the Green Lantern's what we saw in the
first storyline was the de facto death
of Hal Jordan now Sinestro also seemed
to have died too but we don't really
know what happened to them and in fact
here we really focus on we focus on Hal
Jordan now the cool thing is that for
those of you guys who are keeping up
with my videos on Geoff Johns Green
Lantern run a lot of the stuff that
we're going over will start to become
more and more familiar to you the more
we cover Geoff Johns run so it's kind of
cool here for example the daughter of
Sinestro is the one running the Sinestro
Corps now so those are the kind of
things that we start to get into the
kind of things that begin to make sense
to you guys so again it's really kind of
a self fulfilling thing now those are
guys who are watching by your Jeff Jones
Green Lantern videos we're going to do
is we're going to throw this in to the
Jeff Jones video but we're constantly
going to bump these back as we put in
new informations reisel always be at the
very end until we begin to you know sort
of fill out and so on and so forth but
the fact remains here with the end of
how Jordan and the Green Lanterns
sedessa Rose law we kind of saw
something that we'd never really seen
before what we ended up getting was
basically how Jordan's ring which was
made completely by him that we'll talk
about here in a second but of course
what we also do is we have you know Jon
Stewart who's basically leading the
Green Lantern Corps and the daughter of
Sinestro who's leading a Sinestro Corps
and what they've done is essentially
come together because remember at the
end of really kind of going into the new
52 at the tail end of Jeff
John's run and picking up with Robert
and Debbie's run we basically had this
whole scenario where the guardians of
the universe were almost completely and
totally obliterated with the exception
of gambit and saved they were just kind
of exiled out into the middle of nowhere
they've been gone the entire time John
Stewart and the other Green Lantern's
we're essentially kind of out stood
beyond all known existence and kind of
taken all the way back to the very
beginning of the universe's origin and
what it did is it set the stage for the
Sinestro Corps to basically have one of
the land they could essentially
implement their own law you know
operating under the guise of being
protectors and then force the universe
into enslavement of course this
basically resulted in the Green
Lantern's kind of coming back or at
least it was a very coincidental timely
saying they came back they fought
against the the Sinestro Corps and
Sinestro supposedly died and so because
of that we basically have these two
cores operating together the issue is
that despite the fact that really kind
of in shambles so they're really just
kind of hanging on by the skin of their
teeth at the end of the day they are
Green Lantern's and they are the
universe's police force and so they grab
what numbers they have they grab the
Sinestro Corps and they take off to
sector two eight one three which is
basically the whole Vegas sector for the
purpose of responding to a threat now of
course we end up finding out this threat
comes in the form of Starro now this is
a great throwback this is a really
really cool throwback Starro is a filler
villain right Saro is the guy you bring
in when you're launching a new story and
you want to show what the team is about
Starro was the original villain of the
Justice League of America when they were
first created in 1960 he's a very first
villain to the Justice League and he
really kind of has a special place with
a legacy of DC Comics because of that so
he's like the guy that's been at the job
for like thirty years and now he just
doesn't ever do anything but nobody
fires him because he's paid his dues
that's really kind of what happens with
Starr over here I mean I keep the guy on
the couch more or less you know and it's
things like this I think it's really you
know these these small little moments
it's these little great things that make
Hal Jordan the Green Lantern's the best
thing come out of DC rebirth because
it's just these great little tidbits of
history that gets thrown I get kind of
brought into this story now of course
with Starro effectively vanishing you
know essentially disappearing one is up
happening is the Green Lantern's you
know essentially try to chase after him
only to find out that they've been
contained and they're held inside one of
the jars of Brainiac now this is really
kind of cool because again brainiacs big
claim to fame is that he just goes
around putting things in containers now
if we know from our our ingest
this injustice origin videos for
Brainiac because we basically described
the new 52 origin which you'll find down
in the description we know a lot of this
was rooted in the idea that he was
basically trying to save the universe or
save you know all things in existence
from a warring race outside of you know
from another dimension but the fact
remains here that his big thing is just
traveling around the cosmos grabbing
things that are interesting bottling
them up and then just holding them in
place and so effectively the Green
Lantern's em'ly Sinestro court are stuck
inside a giant jar as is being held by
Brainiac which is kind of cool but again
picking up with Hal Jordans Green
Lantern ring we end up finding out that
after he died the ring eventually sought
out ganthet and sayd now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
Green Lantern rings do not do this
remember ganthet and sayd have just kind
of been outside of everything they
really have no idea what's been going on
for the most part I mean they have a
general idea their general understanding
but to their knowledge they didn't know
that how Jordan was dead
not only that they didn't know that how
Jordan forged his own ring under normal
circumstances in the Green Lantern
mythos say for example there's you know
Sector two eight one four which is the
location of earth in the in the DC
universe what usually ends up happening
is the Green Lantern will die and then
it'll say okay Green Lantern of sector
to eight one four is dead searching out
a new Lantern and it will immediately
just hunt down a brand new Lantern that
person will be selected they'll be told
you know you have the power to overcome
great fear they will be selected to
become a Green Lantern and they'll be
whisked off to what would normally be OA
the base of operations for the for the
Green Lantern's right now it's mojo the
giant Green Lantern planet but they'll
be whisked off in order to go through
the training process and be brought in
to you know to being a Green Lantern the
difference here is that this ring is
explicitly looking for Hal Jordan and
that has never happened before it's one
of the coolest things to take place and
the whole Green Lantern landscape and so
what we're going to do here it's for the
most part the whole events with you know
the early conflict with the Green
Lantern's is really just kind of them
facing off against you know star oh and
the little mini stars these use to
basically take over the minds of
different people that's not wildly
important I mean if it's there and it's
something to be read but what Robert
Vendetta is really doing here is
emphasizing Hal Jordan it's really kind
of like the Green Lantern's are a
secondary plot to what's going on with
Hal with regards to his ring searching
explicitly for him what we end up doing
is we actually
with him in the afterlife now he gets
these little glimpses and different
things like that and it's kind of cool
to see this because it's kind of been
Diddy taking his own stance on what
happens when a person dies and it's been
depicted different ways over the course
of DC Comics publication history but
here it's almost like an afterlife
explicitly for the Green Lantern's and
that's not unheard of I mean the Speed
Force is the afterlife for the flashes
for speedsters of the DC Universe and
Marvel Comics people from Asgard who die
honorably they go to hala again like
there's a lot of different things that
go on with regards to how it is that
death is depicted in comic books and
it's always kind of cool to see you know
an individual's own depiction on the
realm of death but in his journey how
Jordan basically comes across a dancer
now this again is a really great moment
of history here because that's what this
is designed to be how Jordan the Green
Lanterns is designed to pay so much
homage to all the work that was done
both by fen detie himself and by Geoff
Johns and so the idea is to basically
give us a lot of these great little
hallmark moments and of course
essentially with what appears to be the
defeat of Starro you know the various
little mini star oohs kind of fall off
the faces the people who have been
captured and so on and so forth and
again we're just kind of touching back
on that a little bit of a conflict here
and there so you guys can sort of
understand what's going on but the fact
remains speaking directly with AB and
Sewer what seems to be happening is avin
sword is effectively easing Hal Jordan
is passing now this is really kind of
cool and it seems like something that
you expect right I mean I don't really
think about death very often you know
but I have thought about scenarios what
would happen when the time comes where I
pass on and I always thought it would be
kind of a cool idea
if you encounter someone who kind of
takes you on this journey it would take
you on this path that helps to ease the
transition between your living and the
fact that you're in the afterlife now
because I imagine to be a pretty jarring
experience to suddenly just be dead well
that's bad you know and it's going to be
whisked away you know to some place or
something on those lines but the factory
ain't here you know with with regards to
Evans sword the whole idea of kind of
easing Hal Jordan is passing also comes
with the notion that Hal Jordan
shouldn't be here and that's what's kind
of crazy is because of all the people
that could have appeared to Hal Jordan
it's a beam sword and so while he's kind
of here to say hey look man like you're
in the afterlife
just so you know if you basically died
you know the idea is to say look man
right now is not your time you are not
supposed to be dead you are supposed to
be alive now this doesn't mean that
Evans
we can see the future it doesn't mean
that he's you know a guy that knows
everything that's going to happen later
on down the line what it does mean is
that how Georgia is going to play a very
intrinsic part and the events to come
because keep in mind everything in DC
Comics is leading up to you know the
whole reveal of The Watchmen and all
that kind of good stuff and that's
really what's going on right now and you
know the Green Lantern's by Sam
Humphreys you know the reason why we're
kind of going back and covering all this
stuff is because we basically have the
Green Lantern Simon Baz and Jessica Cruz
chillin up to receive training alongside
Guy Gardner and Kyle Rayner and so
they're basically going to step into the
role of being tried and trued Green
Lantern's
because all these numbers are being
consolidated all these different
superhero teams are being brought
together armies are being raised all
these preparations for war are being
made with regards to the DC landscape if
you look that's exactly what's happening
Superman is consolidated with his new 52
power and he's stronger than he ever was
all the Green Lantern's are being
recalled back to OA you have all these
different things taking place especially
with the button I'm not going to spoil
anything because it just came out it's
really really good but all these things
are taking place for the purpose of
consolidating numbers and stuff what is
up happening is getting to say basically
reach out and they ain't Kyle Lena they
bring Kyle Rayner over to the location I
keep in mind Kyle Rayner is the White
Lantern and so he can literally reach
into the afterlife and pull how Jordan
out but the crazy thing is that as is
depicted here it's contingent on the
mindset of the person who's already
there and so how Jordan is in a very
confused state he doesn't know what's
going on
I mean he's being told yes you know this
is this is not your time you are not
supposed to pass on yet but for him he's
also kind of accepting to a degree I
mean he's like you know I don't really
know where I am but he's not panicking
he's not freaking out it's nothing like
that you know it's him basically just
kind of like yeah I guess maybe this is
the afterlife you know he's calm he's
relaxed he's not panicking and clamoring
his way back to life again and so
because of that where he does meet all
these other members of the Green
Lantern's who have died you know Tomar
ray and all these various individuals
and it is really cool to see but the
fact remains here the kyle rayner
essentially uses his power reaches into
the ring that is Hal Jordans and tries
to bring him back now that's the cool
thing because the ring is what anchors
Hal Jordan to the possibility of
continuing to live the ring is what
angers in that it's almost as if you
know for example you have fallen down
into a hole and you were just holding on
to the edge
somebody can grab your hand and they can
pull you back up and that's
exactly what kyle rayner is doing with
Hal Jordans rank had Hal Jordan not
forged this ring out of his willpower
all of his essence would essentially be
gone with him because this was again
just a small essence of what Hal Jordan
is it allows Kyle Rayner to reach him to
the ring itself and pull Hal Jordan out
and that's exactly what he does and
that's one of the coolest things to see
is him basically resurrecting Hal Jordan
bringing Hal Jordan back now of course
once how Jordan is here we also end up
finding out that where Brainiac is going
around and gathering up all these
different artifacts and putting them in
containers that while this is a normal
trend of Brainiac Brainiac himself is
actually being controlled by Larfleeze
now there are Green Lantern fans out
there who love Larfleeze
they're like yes Larfleeze you know
there are people who love large leaves
he's got so much character he's such a
cool character so here's the deal
Larfleeze tapped into the to the
emotional spectrum of avarice oh really
emotion of avarice in the emotional
spectrum ie grief he is the greediest
Lantern if mo in the universe it's such
a cool concept too because if you're the
Green Lantern that taps into the emotion
of greed you would be the only Lantern
right I mean if you were the the orange
lantern rather that's happened to the
emotional specter of greed you'd be the
only lanterns and he is he keeps his
central power or he keeps his up power
battery and clothes check his central
power battery is in close check
everything that he values is just kind
of ported because that's what he is he's
a hoarder he's a he's a guy that just
hoard stuff but the other half of this
is the orange lantern court there is no
orange lantern corkers say so because of
the fact that Larfleeze keeps himself as
the only one with an orange Lantern ring
instead what he does is those
individuals that he kills he in turn
makes constructs out of he effectively
catches their essence and makes them
into construction so it's really kind of
a twisted scenario and maybe a fate
worse than death to be taken by
Larfleeze
but what he ended up doing was basically
stumbling across one of the old designs
of the old Bills Bills of Brainiac now
in truth then did you just kind of get
away with this to be honest I mean
there's been so many versions of
Brainiac that have appeared over the
years and so many verses that have been
defeated we would kind of have to
believe that some older models some
obsolete version of Brainiac is just
kind of laying in a junk heap somewhere
in the universe it just makes sense I
mean
it really just kind of makes good sense
with this character but what ends up
happening is because of the fact that
Brainiac exists to basically capture
catalog and store objects Larfleeze
Tate's Brainiac makes him his own and
the two of them just begin going around
for the purpose of capturing artifacts
for a largely to just hoard things
that's kind of a cool idea it's a cool
blending of like-minded Singh's
innocence that Brainiac does exactly
what Larfleeze does the only difference
is that Brainiac doesn't have a Lantern
ring which seeing Brainiac with a
lantern would be kind of cool but again
we're NEX just kind of serving his
purpose here and so of course what Hal
Jordan having been dead or at least you
know having died without having been
aware of the fact that Jon Stewart and
the other lanterns had arrived with Kyle
winter being there and kind of having
been this Shepherd throughout the
universe really kind of helping worlds
thrive and grow and so on he basically
tells how Jordan look the Green Lantern
Corps is back and so how Jordan
immediately races off alongside a chi
layer and gather to say now remember
with regards to the to the return of the
Green Lantern's I wouldn't go as far as
to say that it's like ganthet and sayd
basically saying yeah things are going
to be just like they were before it's
not going to be like that it's not going
to be that way but what it will do is it
will offer a return to normalcy and the
reason why is because of the fact that
when almost all the guardians of the
universe were completely destroyed by
semester who was possessed by the
parallax entity at the time what he did
is he left Gant into state a lot
basically allowing them to experience
emotions guilt remorse different things
like that shame for the different
actions they'd been involved in over the
course of their time as guardians of the
universe and allowed them to stay in
isolation returning back you know what
the reformation of the green lanterns
means the ganthet and sayd can bring
those experiences with them they can
kind of walk away from this idea that
emotion is a weakness and instead see it
for what it is something that could help
them make more rational decisions that
if they were emotionless now of course
again this really kind of begs the
question on you know which one was
better whether they had emotions or when
they didn't have emotions and in fact
only time will tell with regards to this
story but the fact remains here you know
with Hal Jordan with Kyle Rayner with
Gant it's a basically showing up - Mogo
mogul basically says look yes they're
using me as a base of operations they
were recalled to another sector to deal
with a conflict and then all
communications basically vanished now
it's just the search is on for the Green
Lantern Corps the search is on to
basically find them and the Sinestro
Corps now again how Jordan does not know
oh that the Green Lantern Corps and the
Sinestro Corps have joined forces he's
not aware of that and his mind
there's just the Green Lantern Corps now
from here what we actually have is a
really really good instance of Jon
Stewart showing his chops when it comes
to being a good leader and this is one
of the reasons why I really think that
it's high time that Jon Stewart got his
time in the Sun because I think Venditti
is doing a great job with regards to his
character because with Jon Stewart
effectively leading everything you get
to see how capable he is now in truth
under Jeff John's you know all the
lanterns of Earth got theirs Hahnemann
they really got their time in the Sun
they got a chance to for us as the
reader to experience them but I think
that in terms of Jon Stewart being a
tried and true leader of the Green
Lantern's I don't really think that edge
of Lybian showed that for what it was so
I don't think it really showed him you
know for being as capable of a leader as
he is especially now that he has to work
alongside basically his sworn enemy the
Sinestro Corps so what Jon Stewart
basically says is look I know Larfleeze
I know what he's about Larfleeze prizes
his possessions largely it only cares
about the objects that he has if he
begins losing those he'll do almost
anything to get them back he'll just
snatch things up he'll do whatever it is
he has to and so what Jon Stewart says
is our plan should be to work alongside
each other and basically fight each
other now again this is really kind of
cool because we in turn have the
Brainiac Android feeding on this the
Brainiac Android basically says look man
like they're going to they're going to
go against each other and they are going
to lead to their destruction but here's
the deal you can catalogue all different
kinds of events I mean some of these
things are irreplaceable so these things
simply cannot be stopped you can't bring
them back you just don't have the power
to do that and so at the risk of losing
the Sinestro Corps entirely or losing
the Green Lantern Corps in its entirety
largely it basically lashes out and
destroys the bottle and which they're
held which of course leads to them lissa
the Sinestro Corps and the Green Lantern
Corps fighting against the constructs of
Larfleeze now you know which Hal Jordan
stepping in you know how Jordan arrived
in Colerain arriving for a lot of fans
this was a return to the familiarity
they've been looking for for so long we
would get this great full-page slash of
Jon Stewart and an Kyle Rayner and Hal
Jordan and Guy Gardner the four top
Green Lantern's of Earth and a lot of
fans really kind of looked at this and
said this is the Green Lantern's these
are the Green Lantern's that I know the
Green Lantern's I grew up with the Green
Lantern's that I
and Venditti did not do this by accident
this was not an accidental thing these
four for the most part are be Green
Lanterns they alongside all the other
respective fans of these Green Lanterns
will say they are the top lanterns now a
crowd is growing for Jessica Cruz and a
crowd is growing for for Simon bass and
this is most certainly being helped by
Sam Humphreys amazing writing than the
Green Lantern stories but in terms of
the lanterns as we know them those are
the ones that they think of those are
the ones that they believe to be the top
lanterns now of course this also leads
directly into the Green Lantern Corps
and the Sinestro Corps merging into a
singular Corps again how Jordans still
pretty new to all this so he really
hasn't had a whole lot of time to ask
questions and to figure out what's going
on and said we just kind of get a
singular Lantern core which is really
going to be really cool but what this
does is this basically leads into the
return of Saint Walker the blue lantern
somebody understand and somebody
somebody explain this to me why do you
guys like st. Walker's so much and
please don't say because he's awesome
that doesn't answer anything I want to
know why st. Walker is so cool why do
people love him it's a cool name st.
Walker is an awesome name but people
love st. Walker and I just don't
understand why but anyways it's so
pretty interesting you know it's still
pretty gnarly and and yeah guys anyway
if you are new here to come let's
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the raw cork if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]